[Music]
oh hey
Dan happy
anniversary Dan my husband he's an
amazing dad you're almost ready to go to
size 4 rest huh how you so big look at
the big musos I just wish our lives
were
bigger really at least let me put my kid
Down clean up on our six sorry about the
mess hold on
[Applause]
oh hey Bo hey
Dan don't hang up I need no identities
I'm burd me my wife and three kids have
you told them yet I'll tell them when
I'm on the road meet me in Vegas in 3
days this is crazy oh God we're going to
Vegas woo oh so pumped nothing brings
the family together like a road
trip stop
and
with hours on a plane or 33 hours in a
car can someone unlock the car
please call right now
everybody I want him
found what was that little pothole
Maxi's been up the whole time by the
way where that
before I met your mom I was a covert
assassin I escaped at life and now they
found
us what
the being your husband and their father
that's the real
me you're like James Bond in a minivan I
love that
minivan I need to be that guy one last
time for
us look at you BL the family man I'm not
playing is my
[Applause]
life he I'm kind of into spontaneous
dance wait wait
go new
record